hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today I want to talk about something a
little bit different that I've been kind
of looking at with these new images and
some things have been changed and I've
been actually looking way too deeply
into these images I think but I wanted
to share with you guys some of my
thoughts and actually get some help from
you guys in the comments below to kind
of share this idea because once again
I'm not a historian there's a lot of
historical possible inaccuracies with
this image so I just want to make sure
that everything is correct and I'm not
being stupid but yeah like we said
yesterday that Ubisoft had released a
giant post about the upcoming year for
content but some of you may have noticed
something and I noticed it too but I
didn't really think about it that much
in the video when the link was first
released I've clicked on it and it
actually gave me a 404 error code saying
that the website was being edited or
removed and it didn't really bother me
at the time since I was really just
focused on making the video and just
trying to figure out what was going on
in that video so I just refreshed the
page and everything was cool but the
image was changed on screen you're gonna
be seeing a difference between the two
that I saw on reddit ignore the giant
red circle this was the discussion about
a whole different topic about the minion
which we'll get into later but look
above the black prior in the front on
the left side who's that in the
background there is way more than just
that so piece by piece we're gonna be
talking about this and that'll be last
so first up though is the hands some
people have been wondering what this
means and I'm not really sure myself but
the story for this season is that the
Great War has been raging over the past
years and takes an unexpected turn the
earth has quieted down but new leaders
arise in warriors across all factions
need to decide what they're really
fighting for my assumption is that that
on the right hand side is law bringer
with the left-hand side being a
Centurion black prior or maybe even a
Viking I'm not really sure some have
speculated that this is actually a poly
ons armed and holding crosses on the
right which also could fit this theory
as well although I'm pretty sure
apollyon had like claws or some [ __ ] on
her armor and I don't see that here
maybe that was on her one arm but once
again this is purely speculation I mean
even the whole image is literally a
giant chess board so let's assume that
bp's hand is on the left for example it
goes back to the new leaders in who
they're fighting for which is why you
see raider ken say t on d warden and
black prior all
on one side and two black priors a soon
dot and a heat so carry on the other
side if you know anything about this
game that you've been playing for more
than two minutes you know that none of
these characters should be on the exact
same side especially on the right where
at least one of every person in the
faction is on one team they should not
be together they absolutely hate each
other I'm gonna get into a little bit
more of that stuff but like I said I
just wanted to talk specifically about
what the hands are and maybe what that
means because I feel like there's a lot
of symbolism and metaphors to this image
that some people aren't really talking
about and next up is the armor and in
the last video we talked about yesterday
I mentioned how there's going to be new
armor for the new season and I also want
to clarify that it said in the post that
new armor would be coming this year I
thought that meant 2019 apparently they
meant 2020 so if you did see that video
but not miry attitude comment we won't
be getting new armor this year before
the new year starts but we will be
definitely getting new armor for the
characters in year four I just want to
clarify that apparently I read it wrong
but I looked grammatically correct to me
but in this image though I want to point
out a few things that I noticed now I'm
not a warden or a tee handi main but in
my 2,000 hours on this game in the past
three years I have never seen any armor
like that in my entire life and specific
T on DS helmet and wardens shoulder pads
I've never seen that ever so this could
maybe be a small teaser at new armor
coming to the game and what some of it
may look like we will have to revisit
this video when the armor does
officially get confirmed and shown to
see if our suspicions are correct or not
but I think that's kind of what this
image was going for the next one I'm
gonna leave it up to you but this has to
do with the minion and I mean the
minions have been in the game since the
very beginning the very big first game
mode that we've ever been able to play
of course has been Dominion and they've
been here since the beginning yet in any
teaser seasonal or anything like that
they have not been shown or advertised
like this the minions have been slept on
since the very beginning with what the
only change being the seasonal events
that we've been getting for them and
then they just go right back to normal
so I'm hoping that this isn't just some
cool little artwork thing that they're
doing and this actually has something to
do with the possibility that minions
will be coming on a whole different
faction maybe I'll get to play as them
probably not but I'm thinking more
customization
technically in chess when a piece is on
the board it means it's ready to play
and since the minion is about to be put
down I think this is ubisoft's
metaphorical way of saying that the
minions have come to play once again I
think this is more from a customization
standpoint we might be able to actually
get if specific minions so that all the
time that you can only play as the
samurai minions and like on your screen
or maybe something else I just think the
minions are gonna have some sort of play
in year 4 but the moment everybody's
been waiting for like I said this very
mysterious being now year 4 is coming
with two characters one in season two
year four and one in season four year
four if you're like me and you hate that
format and you like talking about in
total numbers that is seasons 14 and 16
because currently we're on season 12 it
says that their arrival will coincide
with the storyline as well as the events
of the year and it's seasons we can't
wait to find out which side you choose
so the character actually looks like
he's wielding a shield and a possible
mace with some spikes on it 90% if not
all maces that have spikes are
automatically morning stars here's the
thing I've talked with some people on my
discord they didn't mention that morning
stars were used but they weren't exactly
incredibly popular so that's why I need
your guy's help I'm not a historian so
either one of us could be wrong but we
have come up with a couple of options
option one is that this is the new hero
and the new hero is going to have a mace
Morningstar kind of vibe with a shield
or this is pretty much just conch with
new armor because it's the only
character in the game that semi matches
who this guy is or three somebody said
in a reddit post that this is just an
upgraded minion yeah let me know if you
guys think about that in the comments
below
overall I think there's going to be a
lot of things moving in year 4 and
there's going to be a decision we as the
players have to make in game like
instead of picking a faction now we may
have to pledge to a different side or
maybe we pick a faction but now we also
have to pledge to a different side
because as I said there's gonna be a lot
of new leaders rising so it might be the
fact that there's going to be team light
in team dark with the image or as some
people have stated team chaos and team
order and also to kind of solidify that
fact also notice how there's three black
priors in this entire image and the one
black prior that's on the light side of
the
image is wearing one of the two non edgy
versions of his armor I feel like that's
kind of saying something yeah but like I
said let me know all of your thoughts
about any of this stuff in the comments
below
preferably in multiple comments to boost
that YouTube algorithm so thank you for
that if you do that ahead of time but
yeah this year's gonna be crazy there's
a lot of things that are gonna be
happening with the game if you haven't
seen yesterday's video definitely go
check that out and like I said leave
your thoughts about all this stuff in
the comments below
I think this stuff's could be [ __ ]
sick and I cannot wait to see what
happens in year four so let's like to be
if you do enjoy those subscribe if
you're new I cover the informational
SATA fauna that being the balance
changes the here updates the Patchett's
and the leaks if any be kept up to date
with everything happening within the
world or honor and never miss out on an
update just like this one definitely
stay subscribe the channel and the guys
take care enjoy the rest of your day
and peace out
you